ce qu'il faut encore retenir de
l'actualité aujourd'hui en france et à
l'étranger en commençant par le jugement
dans la sphère de carpentras sept ans
après la profanation du cimetière juif
quatre hommes ont été condamnés à de la
prison ferme karine shana lionel connu
les profanateurs n'ont exprimé aucune
émotion à l'annoncé du jugement le
tribunal a suivi les réquisitions deux
ans de prison ferme pour patrick la une
est gros et olivier fabry en revanche il
a alourdi de 18 à 20 mois de prison la
peine de yannick garnier bertrand
nouveau
ce jugement est important parce qu'elle
comporte une sanction qui est une
sanction républicaine sur des faits qui
sont des faits il humain et puis parce
que c'est un jugement c'est une décision
qui fera date
de son côté madeleine jam on est restée
chez elle ne voulant pas s'infliger une
épreuve supplémentaire aujourd'hui ce
qu'elle veut c'est oublié j'aime bien
ces eaux là surtout pour ceux que j'ai
eus comme on raconte passe à carpentras
il n'y a pas eu de personnes auraient
déjà dit avec moi ici ni la synagogue ni
l'église